boa tarde gente vive hoje apresento a
vocês a história de um menino que por
acaso sou eu
o menino que odiava estudar mas que
adorava aprender e que acredita que
estudar é chato mas aprender pode ser
divertido passava pensando neto tenho
que ir pra escola tudo aquilo pra mim
era muito chato eu só conseguia ver uma
utilidade em ir pra escola que era a
parte da merenda
isso pra mim foi muito time deu um
grande problema que hoje só que eu
passava horas numa serraria olhando como
que o marceneiro cerrava à madeira para
poder construir o meu carrinho de rolimã
melhor que os dos meus amigos
isso pra mim era um aprendizado útil e
para a escola não conseguia visualizar a
utilidade daquilo que tem uma passagem
interessante nesse momento da minha vida
aproximadamente r com os 11 anos de
idade é que eu construí uma boate na
garagem da casa dos meus pais
o suzano latas de óleo soe a algumas
pessoas pode não saber o que é uma lata
de óleo só eua então é só fechar o olho
e imaginar uma lata de leite condensado
gigante
eu abri essa lata de um lado furava ela
do outro lado colocavam bocal papel
celofane pregava as latas todos os
cantos do teto da garagem é e aí ligava
tudo isso numa tábua porque eu não sabia
fazer lâmpada piscar
então eu fazia pegava tudo numa tábua
ligavam micro system e um dj ficava era
ali na tábua acendendo e apagando do
poder fazer minha boate kiss casa e
colocava lona
preto e cobrava entrada dos meus amigos
mas aí passou um tempo nem fui para a
faculdade até para quem não gosta de
estudar eu estudei muito né
graças à minha mãe que não me deixou
sair da escola e só que eu fui criando
meu próprio jeito de aprender porque né
como já foi falado aqui hoje
cada pessoa aprende do seu jeito
não existe uma única forma que dá para
se ensinar todas as pessoas
eu sentava geralmente as primeiras
carteiras e nunca tive caderno porque eu
tinha um tremendo problema com conseguir
copiar o que o professor falava e eu
ficava perdido naquilo que eu ficava
mais preocupado em copiado quem aprendeu
que estava ensinando
então o que eu fazia eu ficava com os
braços cruzados né
balançando ali pra frente e para trás e
copiava a menina do meu lado tinha ela
ela menina super caxias
o professor espirrava ela abre aspas e
colocava neste momento o professor
espirrou fez chapas
hoje vou tirar xerox essa menina é muito
mais inteligente e vou ficar parado para
manutenção na i por não ficar parado ali
balançando pra frente pra trás assim em
tudo
recebi vários apelidos na faculdade um
deles era autista que eu ficava lá sim
vivendo no meu mundo isolado mas
passou-se algum tempo né
ficava olhando para minha filha que hoje
eu estou tendo um grande presente que
pela primeira vez a minha filha e minha
esposa está assistindo a gente contar a
nossa história né isso é muito
importante porque a minha filha
porque é ela na verdade foi aonde tudo
isso começou porque eu tinha uma questão
minha particular relacionada a gostar de
ir pra escola a gostar de estudar e tudo
e eu comecei a visualizar essas mesmas
coisas na minha filha ela prefere muito
mais brincar coisas legais assim tudo
pra criança do que ter que ir para a
escola e nesse momento muitas pessoas
virá falar pra mim isso pode ser um
problema genético da sua família a sua
família que não gosta de estudar não há
lá eu conhecia lá ela com dois anos de
idade ela não é minha filha de sangue
então isso não é um problema genético é
um problema da sociedade é existe um
episódio que eu gosto muito dos simpsons
que o homer simpson descobre que o
fliperama tentar ensinar uma coisa pra
ele e ele destrói o fliperama inteiro
porque ele não está a fim de aprender
então o ato de estudo se tornar o estudo
algo divertido aprendizado algo
divertido é um desafio muito grande e aí
baseado nesse problema para esse imposto
vou tentar desenvolver uma plataforma
tornar o aprendizado algo divertido
chamei dois amigos
o jean eo flávio com ips petizes
complementares a mim né
o jean é um excelente técnico de beck em
decodificação e tudo e o flávio de na
parte de design e osx pires e nesse
momento é muito interessante é quando
foi montar o negócio não se em conta as
coisas sem dinheiro não tem jeito né
e eu tinha 20 e poucos anos tinha
acabado de pagar a última prestação de
um golf zerinho a juiz de fora da
exigência é tão discrepante em termos de
tamanho com relaxamento sim mas não é
tão simples piraí né então você tá por
exemplo em juiz de fora com golfe 0 20 e
poucos anos de idade
você vai na boate bem arrumado
conseqüência você pega qualquer mulher
da cidade de todas as menininhas a lista
é um carro zero em roma
em boletim eu não tinha essa planta
ainda assim era bem mais fácil
só que tem que fazer abdicar de muitas
coisas então vende o carro paguei a
última prestação vende porque todo
dinheiro né meu pai tinha arrumado um
apartamento que tinha toda a frente de
licenciatura de vidro e tudo que eu todo
dinheiro que eu tinha e ucrânia porque
apesar de testar as coisas ver o que que
engajar mais usuários e então durante
muitos meses
o apartamento ficou todo com papelão na
frente
eu não tinha nem cortina o rack da minha
sala até pouco tempo atrás era uma caixa
de papelão
então você tem que fazer essas escolhas
a sua vida né
daí eu vendi o carro porque tinha mais
duas pessoas trabalhando comigo e
ninguém vive de ar
todo o dinheiro foi colocado no crânio e
o que vem a ser o crânio é grande a
plataforma onde você joga aprende se
diverte acumula uma moeda virtual e
troca por prêmios
quem é o maior inimigo do crânio
aí fica bem fácil de entender o crânio
quem é nosso maior inimigo quente crouch
acho que boa parte dos 12 sabe que é o
que é de praxe quem não sabe já viu
alguém jogando aquele joguinho de matar
docinho na tela que não serve pra nada
né a isso é um passatempo quem falar
isso na verdade já tem que ir logo para
o plano para poder começar a ganhar
alguns cases porque aquilo não é um
passatempo que ele não rouba tempo e ele
vai tomar no seu bem mais precioso na
sua vida que é o seu tempo você passar
horas ali matando o docinho e no final
você faz o que é aquilo a não ainda tem
uma parte você começa a encher o saco
dos outros pedindo vida e manda uma vida
me manda uma vida me manda uma vida que
se faz com a vida depois serve pra nada
então qual é a idéia do crânio mesmo
momento que você está interagindo num
momento desse você acabou de chegar no
aeroporto ali tudo ou saiu da escola em
casa resolveu seu facebook o foursquare
resolveu tudo o que você vai interagir
no seu celular com que você vai se
envolver de conteúdo que tinha gregg
aí você pega e vai para o resto da vida
não pelo amor de deus você vai pro
crânio aí você pega entra no avião
começa a jogar sobre um conteúdo que te
interessa ele pode ir desde é matemática
corte costura física quântica
estamos colocando agora praticamente
todos os times de futebol
estamos começando pelo melhor deles o
flamengo
nós já temos praticamente todos os times
do rio já estão com a gente aí que é o
legal dessa questão do time do rio né
time de futebol a gente tentando dar uma
camada de conteúdo de algo útil para a
história do clube para outras
modalidades além do futebol também e o
que eu faço com isso eu trago usuário
para dentro da plataforma do crânio e
depois eu faço um croceri de conteúdo ou
seja eu ofereço esse usuário uma outra
interação que seja por exemplo jogar
todas as provas do enem desde a primeira
edição acumular que é isso e trocar
depois por um lanche que seja no spoleto
no bob's aonde for
então ele consegue dar utilidade para
aquilo então incentivo e muitas vezes e
trazer como homer simpson você trazia
pessoa para aquilo é difícil então eu
uso o futebol que é algo que todo mundo
gosta
no brasil isso é consenso então isso é o
crânio
já operamos hoje em oito plataformas
aqui não estamos falando do site
facebook android iphone e blackberry
o que eu acho muito legal que o sms o
crânio das poucas interações que eu
conheço que você consegue jogar você
responde pergunta troca de categoria
muda de idioma o crânio já funciona em
quatro idiomas português inglês espanhol
e português de portugal se consegue
treinar também só sou o seu estudo
nacional de idiomas estudar nesse
sentido né e já estão agora sendo
proibidos fone 11 28 também subindo
agora firefox do s etc
a ideia é ter capilaridade por isso que
eu gosto do sms o que hoje tem um
percentual de uso de smartphone
porém o sms qualquer pessoa que tenha um
celular até convencional ela envia-la
crânio para 40 333 aqui no brasil e
consegue usufruir de tudo isso
nessa idéia de você jogar a aprender e
se divertir e trocar por prêmios nós já
entregamos aproximadamente 5 mil prêmios
nem todo o brasil e já mandamos mais de
30 prêmios proacre e 5 o acre existe ou
pelo menos eu mandei 30 prêmios pra lá
está nos correios e entregamos prêmios
em outros países o portugal por exemplo
agora que a gente colocou o português
portugal está entregue aproximadamente
dez prêmios toda semana em portugal
enfim além disso já temos mais de 14
milhões de perguntas respondidas
já estamos agora essa semana com
alcançando 1 milhão de pessoas em uma
plataforma em 117 países
eu tenho um usuário na antártida que eu
estou rezando para ser um pingüim porque
logo aumenta o número de possíveis
usuários de todos os seres humanos mais
os pingüins e aí vem aquela pessoa é
onde o crânio que chegar quando falamos
hoje em rede social que vem na cabeça da
gente de cara o facebook não tem jeito
sem falar em foto web instagram
você pode sair perguntando pra todo
mundo rede social que lhe veio à cabeça
facebook foto instagram
tá aí a gente vai falar me blog ou rede
profissional linkedin miniblog twitter
agora quando nós falamos em educação não
existe um aplicativo que é consenso
porque a educação pela natureza já é de
nicho
você resolve o problema de matemática
para criança você resolve o problema de
idiomas se resolve todos os problemas
então é difícil ter um único ep é que
vai resolver tudo isso é pra massa né em
qualquer o anseio do crânio objetivo do
crânio até 2017 c o aplicativo
referência do setor de educação e
entretenimento para a massa presente na
primeira tela de todos os smartphones ao
redor do mundo
então você vai jogar se vai usar seu
facebook foursquare é twitter linkedin e
depois quando você quiser alguma coisa
útil para poder usar bem o seu tempo
você vai pro crânio e aí com isso hoje
por exemplo a gente está agora já
estamos com escritórios em vários países
por elevar esse conceito não é porque eu
estava tentando aliar o entretenimento à
educação o que eu acho mais legal disso
tudo
imagina que qualquer pessoa não importa
a classe socioeconômica ela pode tar na
austrália interior da áfrica no brasil
nos estados unidos
ela começou a interagir que não seja com
o enem por exemplo que seja com física
quântica conseguiu aprender algo ou
ratificar um conhecimento que ela tem
acumulou que é isso e trocou por exemplo
por um tablet por um ipad e teatro
ela conseguiu aprender a gente levou pra
ela um conhecimento e ela talvez sem
condições de adquirir um bem é demais
elite conseguiu adquirir aquilo com a
inteligência dela com o conhecimento que
adquiriu qual o valor social disso em
seu crânio gente muito obrigado